hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of their semi-final match demo
java versus daniel dubo uh rajab won the
first match yesterday and now uh dubo
needs to bounce back to somehow
uh tie the result and then go into tie
breaks and uh he's not doing all that
great he already lost game one and now
he really needs a win
and he has the black piece so can he do
it uh or will
rojo just take it all so without further
ado let's see what happened in game two
rajab
with the white pieces opens with knight
to f3 again we have the retti like in
the previous game
knight f6 and now c4 transposing into
the english opening with b6 and now
d4 bishop to b7 fiance doing the light
square bishop and now
g3 rajab wants to do the same g6
and bishop to g2 we have bishop to g7
duba with the double fianchetto
uh and both players castle so castles
castles and now
knight to c3 so just continuing
development and here dubo trades off a
pair of knights he goes
knight to e4 and rajab accepts knight
captures bishop captures and now
bishop to e3 that looks like a funny
move since it blocks the e2 pawn but
this way white is not committing
committing to anything if
you go for something like e3 then black
goes d5 and
it's a funny position the bishop is
still on c1 and you don't really have
anything to show for his white
so bishop to e3 actually the top move uh
by theory
and now c5 striking in the center
putting pressure on that d4 pawn
so queen d2 preparing bishop to h6 to
trade off
the dark square bishops and d6 now by do
both and just bishop to h6
rajabov goes for the exchange knight to
d7
continuing development and now rook f to
d1
we have knight to f6 and here uh rajab
of trades on g6 and completes his
development with bishop captures king
captures and
rook a to c1 and now white finished his
development and black needs to do the
same
so queen to c7 do both develops the
queen connects the rooks and now
uh this position has been reached before
with bishop to f1 and b4 being the known
moose here but rojo
goes uh knights to h4 and it's now a new
position that we have on our hands uh uh
starting from move 15.
so the bishop here is under attack and
uh but also defended so
uh the double just continues developing
with rook eight to b8
uh later on maybe you can bust open the
position with it with a move like b5 and
now comes
bishop captures on e4 knight captures
and just queen to e3
again uh the e2 pawn is still on e2
haven't
uh it still hasn't moved but that's how
this opening goes so knight back to f6
as the knight was under attack and now
queen to g5 better job of uh placing his
queen on the same file as the king now
knight to f5 could be a bit tricky so
you have to be careful
uh so arjabu just goes back king to h8
uh and now comes queen to h6 so
uh what what is the queen doing there
well for the moment not much
but rajab has some plans of bringing the
knight back to f3 then to g5 to put
pressure on h7
but as long as black's knight is on f6
you're not really going to do anything
so rook f2c8 dubo just ignores him and
knight back to f3 preparing to bring it
to g5 now that
the rook left the defense of the f7 pawn
knight to g5 will
come with tempo so king to g8 now
defending the f7 pawn and b3 now just
strengthening the position on the queen
side we have a6
and now knight to g5 and now the knight
can never move otherwise captures and
checkmate
so here queen back to d8 preparing queen
f8 he wants to kick away uh a job of
screen and their java just goes back
knight f3 in case of queen f8 then you
can bring back the queen so the knight
is not in your way
uh and here uh queen to d7 uh just
getting the queen to a more active
square also
uh if the white queen ever moves you can
always bring your queen to h3 could be
very annoying then black goes knight g4
and then
all of a sudden it's black who's on the
attack so king g2 preventing that and
now
queen to e6 by dubaf he somehow wiggles
his queen
deeper into the position so the e2 pawn
is under attack at a job of defensive
rook d2 and now queen to e4 a beautiful
centralizing move by
do both now pinning the knight and again
uh king to f1
simply unpinning but you have to be very
careful if you ever move this knight
then you run into queen to h1 checkmate
so you don't want to do that
so uh rook to c7 and
now comes rook to d3 the rook no longer
needs to be
guarding this pawn and now rook to e3
might be a problem
uh in some some lines uh we have queen
to f5
and now comes king to g2 again keeping
an eye on this h3
square we have queen back to e4 again
pinning the knight and king to f1
and here duval would most likely be uh
satisfied with a draw
uh but uh since he's down so much in the
match of course he doesn't want to draw
he wants to push
even though he has the black pieces so
rook beat the c8 and now
d5 better job not allowing duval to open
up the
uh the c file and now this queen is
looking very suspicious there as
these six squares covered the e5 square
is covered so a lot of these scores are
covered and
if moves like h3 and g4 appear on the
board that queen will not have a lot of
squares so here
b5 you want to bust open the position as
soon as possible
but the just h3 capturing right away
doesn't really do anything for you
because just throw captures and the
queen is
in even more trouble so instead after h3
uh we have
rook to b8 uh just uh
uh preparing to now maybe capture and
then try and bring the rook
in via the b file but g4 now
and now uh with this h3 and gpu g4 pawns
being
pushed forward the g4 and f5 squares
have been
uh made unavailable to the black queen
and now it's uh looking really scary
rook the e3 is coming and what do you
play here
you have to play something so e5
now uh taking care of this problem
because now if rook to e3 you do not
trap the queen queen can come to f4
so instead here we have d captures an e6
alpha song and now of course the queen
has to capture if you capture with the
pawn then you lose the pawn here
so uh we have queen captures on e6 by
dubai but now uh by doing this he also
weakened his d6 pawn and now this is
exactly what rejabu will go for
queen to f4 and d6 spawn is a backwards
pawn so
uh you're not uh going to be able to
push it forward especially
like maybe you could but the problem is
that
the rooks are here so you're going to
lose material if you do that
so knights the e8 defending the pawn and
now rook to e3
challenging the queen here queen back to
d7 and now again
knight to g5 and now uh you constantly
have pressure here on f7 but your main
idea is knight to e4 and
from there the knight will uh be very
strong as it will either
f6 square so this knight is very much
stuck here
so d5 double finally pushes that pawn
but
it comes with a price c captures queen
captures
and now what do you do here well you
definitely don't go for material here
because if you win material captures
characters and captures
then dubois again checkmates you queen
to h1 checkmate dubove is a very sneaky
guy
so here king to g1 of course rajabo
doesn't fall for that
and now c4 do both managed to open up
the position and
creates a past pawn here so captures
captures
the past pawn is created and now knight
to e4 and here
you have to be very careful because that
f6 square is a is a terrible one
and you also have ideas in the position
like queen captures on c7
then knight captures queen and then
knight f6 check picks up the black
queen so crazy stuff here uh so duval
has to move the rook
rook c to b7 and now uh rajabo just
finds another tricky
tricky shot rook captures on c4 making
it impossible for the queen to capture
it
because just knight f6 check and you
pick up the queen
so here after rook captures on c4 uh
it's hard for for dubuque to find the
move especially a move that allows him
to gain some sort of a winning position
because he needs a win to get back into
the match
uh it's very hard he plays rook to b1
with check
we have king to h2 uh and now comes
queen to d1
so threatening queen to g1 checkmate but
rajav just starts a nice king walk king
to g3
and now the problem with queen g1 check
just king h4 and you don't have any
moves here you can't play some like f6
or h6 to get the g5 in or anything
but even if you could it wouldn't really
help you so here instead we have
h5 by double uh
advancing the pawn right away but now
rook to f3
immediately going after that f7 square
and you don't have
all that much to do here now with f5 by
dubo not
attacking that knight here but just g
captures on f5 you don't have time to
recapture
so do finds another brilliant attempt
queen to h1 and again if rajava plays a
bit too quick for example if you play
something like czech hoping for queen to
f7
then he actually loses the game because
of rook g1 check
king h4 and the rook to g4 beautiful
the pawn cannot capture due to the pin
and you will have to give up the queen
captures characters
characters and captures uh but uh uh
with uh uh black having a queen now in
the white uh
not having one is going to be a very
easy victory for black so instead after
queen to h1 we have the immediate king
the h4
uh by by rajab and now it's very hard to
find a good move for uh for black
because there aren't any
so here rook the g1 was played still
hoping to get that rook to g for chicken
but now feel free to pause the video and
win the game for the job
as it's actually a forced mate and 8 so
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting
any of the moves that win but knight to
f6 check is the quickest one
so congratulations to everyone who found
it and uh the problem is
you cannot capture because of queen
captures here and if you don't capture
if you move the king
then just captures with check captures
and now rook the c7 check and now
whatever you do
you're you're going to lose the queen
covers h6 you have to go back
king to g8 now queen to c4 check and
that's it wherever you go if this then
this is checkmate and if you go to h8
then another queen d4 check here and now
let's say queen to
g7 is checkmate so this was quickest but
rajab doesn't want to spend too much
time looking for forced ideas he just
plays rook to g3
and now there really is no way for dubo
to continue this game
uh duval played rook to b5 probably with
the idea that
if this check comes then he can capture
as the
rook will not be hanging here uh but uh
rajaw just played rook the c8 and it was
in this position that
daniel dubo resigned the game uh which
is incredible after defeating world
champion magnus carlsen he loses the
tamer rajabov
and not just loses but also that is
crushed by rajab as
out of the last four games they played
our job of won all four games so that's
that's incredible
uh but as rajab said in an interview as
you can see in the quote above the board
he said
i was trying to cool him down as much as
i could this way it worked
this was the strategy i had in the match
to play as boringly as possible so this
is
uh what you have to do against the
spectacular attackers and it's something
for example
i don't know if for those of you who are
older subscribers to the channel might
remember the 1959 candidates tournament
uh where uh miho tal just obliterated
everyone except for one player uh paul
karis
was uh uh was able to crash doll in all
of their games and
uh the problem was he knew how to stop
tal's attacks and no one else could do
that and
tal just obliterated everyone but even
though uh kerris had a positive score
in the candidates tournament tal
actually won and challenged botwinnik
as he just had more points against
everyone else
but the point my point being uh you have
to have a different approach against the
great attackers than just
allow them to to do whatever they want
here dubo resigned because there is no
defense whatever you play let's say king
f8 you defend
against rook captures knight anything
just wins here queen d6
check of course the knight cannot
capture let's say king g7 now queen
captures on g6 with
check and just a very nice checkmate
whatever black plays
uh so after this beautiful rook the c8
move uh dubo resigned and it is
timur rajab who is the first finalist
and we'll see what happens
in the other match uh which we haven't
shown any game so far but
uh we will get to it i haven't had all
that much time since
we're kind of in the middle of something
but i will i will definitely get to it
before
the actual finals uh so yeah
uh that's uh that's the game i do hope
you guys enjoyed it uh dubo really
probably hasn't i mean it's it's
difficult uh the defeating world
champion magnus carlsen and then going
into the match and losing
four games in a row is not an easy thing
to you know withstand but we'll we'll
see
what happens uh uh the the next time he
he joins an elite tournament and how
will
he deal with uh you know someone who
doesn't just let him attack or do
whatever he wants
but yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank hulk
and blow
uh henry minor uh tanish patil lucas
teocaris and
shepard stevens for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day